it's time for the long gene Chronos code
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene with nor
what's company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Chronos cope Larry lesser from
the CBS television news staff and
kenneth crawford national affairs editor
of newsweek magazine our distinguished
guests for this evening is the honorable
george a Dondero united states
representative from michigan in this
reporters opinion if this 83rd congress
goes down in history for nothing else it
will be known as a congress which passed
the st. Lawrence Seaway bill a bill a
measure which opens up a 2,500 mile
waterway through the heart of the United
States now our guest tonight is the
chairman of the House Public Works
Committee and therefore was highly
instrumental in the passage of that
measure representative Ann Darrow you've
been a champion of the st. Lawrence
Seaway for 20 years now why do you think
it's a good thing for our country
because it provides a new Avenue or
highway of water transportation and
water transportation the Great Lakes
area is the cheapest transportation in
this world well do you feel it's a
purely regional measure that it will
help the Great Lakes cities and do harm
to the other seaports of United States
the Atlantic seaports like Philadelphia
New York no sir I do not I look upon it
as a national measure of national
benefit to all of our people and I do
not think that the eastern seaboards and
the ports that you name will be affected
adversely to any extent that they will
even notice mister Dondero this has
always been so in your opinion I know
why was it held up so long where did
this opposition come well it came from
three sources the coal industry fought
it the railroads fought it and also this
seaports along the Atlantic and the Gulf
of mix what in Europe
was the consideration that finally put
it over got around this opposition to
things the determination on the part of
Canada to build it alone in case we did
not care to participate with it and
secondly the discovery of what may be
the largest deposit of iron ore in the
world
in the wilds of Labrador and Quebec well
that brings me to this point mr.
congressman a lot of congressional
critics say that the reason the
administration has been so favorable
towards the Seaway is because two of the
most potent friends of President
Eisenhower are members of the steel
industry and one of them is as you know
mr. Humphrey in the cabinet now how much
weight would that interest of the steel
industries have because we know now that
iron ore must come from elsewhere than
the Mesabi Range in your part of the
country it had nothing to do with it
whatever the iron ore question did
because we have to admit that the iron
ore deposits of the United States are
diminishing rapidly because we're using
a hundred million tons a year and
witnesses before my committee testified
that by 1960 which is only six years
away we will use a hundred and fifty
million tons hour or perhaps will vanish
in the next ten to fifteen years and it
had to be provided from some other
source this is actually true that we
there's a lot of war in latin america
that we can get a hold of and liveliest
everyone into philadelphia right now
that's true and it comes into the Port
of Baltimore but in case of war or
trouble with a foreign fold we become a
very vulnerable nation when we are
compelled to bring that all across the
water just as what happened in the last
war when six out of eight ships bringing
ore from Chile to the United States
we're sunk by the German submarines in
the Gulf of Mexico mr. Don Daryl I was
going to ask you don't you feel that
President Eisenhower's insistence that
this was necessary as a as a measure of
preparation for war had something to do
with overcoming the opposition
ultimately I think it was a major reason
added to the other fact that raw
materials in greater amount are coming
to the United States from Canada
every year this provides one way to
bring them cheaper and in larger
quantities well representative Dondero
mr. Humphrey the present secretary of
the Treasury was once against the Seaway
until in 1949 it was discovered the that
these tremendous ore bodies lay up in
Labrador and it's also true that the
Hanna company which he represents which
controls National Steel has spent about
two hundred thousand dollars in in
lobbying since 1949 so you mean against
the Seaway for the same way when he
changed his mind no doubt the discovery
of ore in Labrador and their interest
there one of the companies that are
exploring and and developing the ore in
Labrador and Quebec however I don't
think that entered into it very much the
steel companies of the United States are
searching this world for new deposits of
iron ore not a lonely Republic steel
that's represented by the Hana people
for George Humphrey who was interested
in it but all the steel companies of
this country had been looking all over
this world in Africa for new deposits of
iron ore because we're using it in such
increased quantities the steel industry
is expanding the Mesaba range is about
worn out is that true well the best
figure we get it'll last maybe 10 to 15
years that's the open pit rich iron ore
then Labrador will become the principal
source it will become a source added
with that or before that time because
the estimate is that we'll bring in 20
million tons of ore as soon as the new
canal of the st. Lawrence Seaway is open
from Labrador represented in Darrell one
of the arguments against the Seaway has
always been that it's closed up for
three or four months of the year when
the Great Lakes freeze over now what are
we going to do when those lakes freeze
over and we have no iron ore to get
across we've answered that for 75 years
on the Great Lakes area by bringing down
the ore that is required for the steel
industry and stockpiling it in the eight
months when navigation is open we have
no trouble whatever in regard to that
and the same rule that applied in
bringing ore from Duluth Minnesota will
apply to bring it up the st. Lawrence
with the same ships in using the same
buddy you have Duluth it seems to me
that when Herbert Hoover first proposed
the Seaway long time ago he wanted it to
run right up to Duluth now this isn't
the same Seaway just goes as far as
Villiers like Erie doesn't it as for 27
feet and someday in the future maybe not
for 10 years or 20 years if they want to
deepen the canals that is the connecting
channels of the Great Lakes like the
Detroit River 227 feet they can do it
it's 25 feet now and on that 25 feet we
have been able to
well we better say we've been able to do
about 25 percent of a waterborne
Commerce of the entire United States mr.
Don Darrell how much will it cost and
how will it be paid for it'll cost the
United States shares 105 million dollars
and it is the only project on the North
American continent which will be paid
for by tolls to be charged against those
who use the new canals and the new locks
in the st. Lawrence Seaway and Canada
share Canada shares a little less than
two hundred million dollars because she
has four locks to build while we only
have three and in addition to that she
will be compelled to lower the Welland
Canal by two feet you mean actually the
people who are going to use the Seaway
will actually pay for its cost Oh in the
long run they will and the period of
amortization is 50 years let's go down
there with some people I think think of
this as as a project designed primarily
to make Chicago and Duluth and the
middle western cities great seaports
that the Queen Marie will sail into
Chicago Arbor and so on well about it
that's not true the Queen Mary and
battleships couldn't use the canal it
would take about 73 percent of the ocean
ships if they want to use it but in my
judgment the major part of the Commerce
of the st. Lawrence Seaway will be
domestic Commerce it will not be foreign
commerce
such as iron ore and a wheat shipment
bulk shipments petroleum and petroleum
products there will be some foreign
commerce to be sure okay really as a
matter of fact you now see a foreign
ship in the Great Lakes do you know yes
sir the little 14-foot canal that Canada
built and she had more
than we did fifty-five years ago bring
in little ships 250 feet long about
2,500 tons capacity representative
Dondero
what ports do you expect on the Great
Lakes will benefit most from the sea are
16 major ports on the Great Lakes such
as Toledo Cleveland Ashtabula Lorraine
Detroit and then growing up around
Saginaw Bay City Chicago Milwaukee on
the Wisconsin coach Duluth Minnesota and
so on superior Wisconsin of course they
won't all benefit equally which what you
expect will be the great st. Lawrence
port in the future then I don't think
you can say that any one part will be
the great st. Lawrence port all of the
ports that wish to can use the st.
Lawrence Seaway commerce now do you
think that the actual passing of the
measure under the Eisenhower
administration will have a pervasive
effect on the coming congressional
elections and your part of the world I
doubt it very much perhaps those who
were for it might gain something by then
I can say to it it's not a partisan
measure in the least it's bipartisan
both parties supported it both in the
Middle West Republican and Democratic
congressmen all supported it Rosen
Dondero you are very optimistic and may
well be because you have a right to be
about the st. Lawrence Seaway but what
about the coming congressional elections
do you feel quite as optimistic about
those as a Republican that's a political
question and perhaps there are many
people in the country who are
disappointed nevertheless the Eisenhower
administration has accomplished some
real things and this st. Lawrence Seaway
that we're discussing in my judgment is
one of the major accomplishment of the
president's administration
representative when will it be ready
when we'll be able to go to a five-year
go to Duluth it'll take five years to
build it the end of that time I hope and
I said so to the president that he and I
could take a trip on the first ship
through it and who's going to build it
the ill private industry or the army or
the Corps of army engineers of the
United States and the Canadian Corps
of Engineers and will have supervision
and control of it some of the work will
be led out to private contractors the
Army and United States do that all over
our country now will we be able to get
any hydroelectric power out of it or
loop will this hurt the potential of the
state law no hydroelectric oh the power
and the navigation must be built
together because the dams that will
furnish the hydroelectric power are also
the dams that furnish the water for the
canals for navigation well thank you
very much for everything I've done taro
for some very informative except the
opinions expressed on the launching
Crona scope were those of the speakers
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching Crona scope was Larry
Ellis sir and Kenneth Crawford our
distinguished guest was the Honorable
George a Dondero United States
representative from Michigan